welcome my name is rob sanders i'm a
course instructor at simplylearn
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank
using seo and seo is search engine
optimization
also known as organic search you also
may as hear
us say organic listings we're going to
talk a little bit about
why you'd want to rank your website in
organic search
okay what is search engine optimization
then we're going to follow that up with
how does google rank websites so why
does it rank one website over another
and how do we get our website to rank
number one
then we're going to talk about the
different types of seo or search engine
optimization techniques so you can get
your website ranked number one
and then we're gonna finish that off
with the do's and don'ts of seo
so let's get right to it and talk about
why seo
so we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you
have a blog you're a food blogger you're
passionate about food
and your niche is ice cream and let's
just say you have a lot of ice cream
recipes
you want to get traffic to your blog you
want people to read your blog
and you're curious why am i not ranking
for my blog why when people type in ice
cream recipes and
say google my blog posts don't appear
at the top of organic rankings and
there's a number of reasons why
you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes
and the main reason would be your
competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you when they have more content
and more blog posts and more pages for
google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason
the other reason is improper usage of
keywords and we're going to talk a
little bit
or it's actually a lot more about you
know keyword usage
in your content so what kind of keywords
do you want to rank for that's really
what we're talking about when we talk
about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content
another reason is port link building
practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website
and so it's all about link building and
with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another
and it's external linking are other
websites of high quality
linking to us and so that's what we talk
about when we talk about link building
and then another reason is web page load
time so
you could be running your blog post on
say wordpress for example
and your blog post isn't loading fast
enough
well if you look at it this way think
about it if you're google
would you really want to rank a website
or blog post in this example number one
on google rankings
if that particular page loaded very slow
no you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link
in organic search and went to your
website they're going to have a bad
experience
because the page is going to load slow
so google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience
and so that's why web page load time is
a critical factor for ranking so we need
to make sure
that our web pages load fast and then
your user experience is not good enough
so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time
google wants people to have a good
experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot
at play there specifically web page load
time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or
overbearing ads on the web page they
want people who
are searching for something in
particular let's just say ice cream
recipes
and they want to find a relevant website
that has ice cream recipes
they want to be able to click on that
link and read some good content about
ice cream recipes it's that simple and
that's really what google's trying to
create in their environment and that's
you as an end user as a website owner
you want your users to have a good
experience
and then last but not least your website
is de-indexed by mistake and really what
we mean
is the indexed is google needs to be
able to
index all the pages on your website so
if you have a blog
with a hundred recipes you want google
to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search
so let's move on to what is seo
so sticking with our ice clean blog
theme
really seo search engine optimization
really is the practice of increasing
your pages
that google has indexed up the rankings
so the end result is we want all our
pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords
so if you want to be ranked for ice
cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do
so that's generally how it works we need
to apply search engine optimization
to increase a page for keyword we want
to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition
and so the competition in this
particular case is evaluated on the
basis of
is the content relevant are they using
suitable titles
for their essay do they have structure
when they're participating in this essay
or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable
these seem all logical for an essay
competition well
guess what they seem logical for seo
because that's exactly how seo works
it's exactly all those points i just
made mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important
in seo and so we need relevant content
we need titles for our pages google
needs to be able to see
structure we need to have synopsis of
what the page is about and that's called
the meta description
and then again the content needs to be
readable and that's important
and so in order to be readable again
we're going to talk
more about site speed because site
speeds important okay
and when we talk about responsive design
when i say response design that means
your site your page needs a load both on
desktop
and also on mobile and so all these
things are important just like an essay
competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine
what page is best to rank number one
number two number three etc
on google search and then link building
remember i mentioned link building a
moment ago
well link building internally and
externally also plays a vital role
and so we're going to talk about that a
little bit later in the class when we
talk about
off-page seo how does google rank
websites
and basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website
they need to crawl your website they
need to take what they call
back to their servers and when they take
it back to their servers
your web pages they need to you have
them available
for indexing so when somebody actually
types in a keyword into google.com
it'll be available to be found on
organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query
is to basically rank the those pages
that they've indexed
from number one to infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query
so really it's about crawling indexing
and ranking
so crawling is simply a process done by
which
google has bots and what these bots do
is they go to
your web server and they're going to
crawl
every page that they can find and how do
they find these pages well they
basically follow links
you might have heard the term spydering
but that's what they call search engine
spidering so basically what google's
doing is they're
building a web so to speak all the links
that they're following
and so when they can follow all these
links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it
on their servers so it's available in
their index
so based on this method google finds out
which websites have relevant content and
which ones don't based
on certain keywords that are typed into
google because if they can't crawl your
website you're not going to be found
and if you can't be found then you're
not going to show up for relevant
keywords so
we need to make sure your site's
available to be crawled and we'll talk
about that a little bit later
okay but let's show you an example so
let's just go
to google search and if i type in the
keyword simply learn
okay i could see i have 1 million 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn
okay now they may not all be simply
learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically
and there are 1 million 10
000 pages related to the keyword simply
learn
now when it comes to organic search we
don't want to get it confused with paid
search so anytime you see
paid search you're going to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see
that there are paid ads here but when it
comes to organic search those are
generally below
paid ads and so that's where google
counts the
1 million 10 000 results and so that's
the whole idea behind
crawling and indexing google is able to
cross simply learn's website
and based on all the pages that they
gather they're going to make those pages
available
in organic search so if you type in a
keyword
and your web page is not available for
indexing
then you're never going to show up for
that keyword so that's why it's
important to make sure your website
is available for crawling and indexing
and so when a user types a query on
search google search the most relevant
websites
that are in google's index are going
appear in the search results
so in the example i gave was simply
learn
well simply learn is the brand name of
the company simply learn so there's a
lot of relevancy there so that's why you
see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo
and why seo we talked about that user
experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example
simply learn is relevant to a lot of the
simply learned pages because
that's who they are simply learn however
simply learn also needs to make sure
that you know for their pages the page
load time
is fast meaning these pages load very
fast for the end user
and google also takes into account other
factors
like how long someone is staying on a
website or are they bouncing meaning are
they going to one page that they land on
and then leaving the website okay and so
the user experience is very very
important
there are other factors also like
language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in
india the results are going to be a
little bit different than say the
results in the united states
why because google is indexing as many
web pages as they can find
so if somebody's doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us
because google has different bots and
these bots are crawling different pages
at different times
and so google's index is updating
continuously
but it's not real time syncing so if you
do a search in india
you may not see exactly the same thing
because both search engines
the google in india and the google in
the us are may not be
exactly synced up so an example would be
you know if you're looking for cafe so
if you search a cafe
and say san francisco you're going to
see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be
local search here at the top there may
be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because
one location but two google search
engines in
india and united states google.com
aren't exactly synced up exactly at the
same exact time you do that search
so location is important language is
important
and relevancy is important along with
user experience
so all those are important factors in
how google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types
of seo now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on google we're
going to have to
apply search engine optimization and so
there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page seo
and off-page seo so first we're going to
talk about on-page seo
so on-page seo is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say
optimizing your own website there's
certain elements on your website and on
your web pages
that we need to take into account and so
some of those elements are
headers meta descriptions title tags
linking so all of those elements are
something we can control
as an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google
and before we do anything with our
website
the first thing we need to do is
understand
what keywords we want to rank for in
order to understand what keywords we
want to rank for
we need to do keyword research and if
you do
anything in seo keyword research is the
most important activity that's the most
important thing you can do
for seo and why do i say it's the most
important because
you need to understand if you choose a
keyword that you want to rank for you
need to understand
how much traffic you're going to get
from that keyword if you're ranked
organically say number one on google so
how much traffic will you get if you're
ranked number one on google
so you need to understand what the
volume is and then number two we need to
understand what the competition is for
that keyword that you want to rank for
so if you choose a keyword and there's
not much competition for it
then chances are you can rank for that
keyword
for a web page on your website quicker
than say
a keyword that has a lot of competition
so we need to understand those two
basic factors volume and competition
before we choose a keyword
and it's it's simply the practice of
going through the motions
of getting your volume and getting your
competition data
so you can choose the keywords you want
and then once you choose the keywords
you want
then you can go and apply on page seo
you can change the title tag the meta
descriptions
the headers all those elements can be
changed but first you need to choose
your keywords
and so again the primary components
we're looking for
are how much traffic you can get or the
search volume
how much competition there is for that
keyword and of course
relevancy okay you need to be able to
choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for
and so let me show you example how to go
through this so the first thing we want
to do
is we want to use a tool and the tool i
would recommend
is google keyword planner and why do i
choose google keyword planner because if
we're trying to rank on google.com
or google search engine we want to be
able to get the data right from the
source
so google's going to be able to give us
information about
how much volume a keyword has and how
much competition it has
so let me show you an example so if i
want to use google's keyword planner
and i want to rank for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing
specialist then i'm going to type that
keyword into
google's keyword planner and what
google's going to do is they're going to
give me
some trends about how much volume
this particular keyword gets over the
course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that that appear
for both desktop
and mobile so mobile is important
because
people start their search process a lot
of times on their mobile device
so we want to be able to get data from
mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month
over the last 12 months we can see how
much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average
on average over the past 12 months i
could see how to become a digital
marketing specialist
is averages 30 searches a month
and this is on google.com and so google
gives us the volume
what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see
google says for that particular keyword
the competition
is medium and so in the google's keyword
planner what they also do is give me
other
relevant keywords that i might think
about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword
so how to become a digital marketing
specialist they're going to also
offer up other types of keywords that
are relevant
so just digital marketing specialist
social media marketing specialist
so for those keywords i can see the
volume so for example
digital marketing specialist i can see
the average volume
is 1 000 per month on average of the
last 12 months
i can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect
all your relevant keywords okay and put
all your relevant keywords
in a spreadsheet and when you put all
these relevant keywords in a spreadsheet
you want to get the data on those
keywords
and the data i'm referring to is the
volume and competition
so in this case we have volume from
google planner google's keyword planner
and i have competition from google's
keyword planner
and so if i go into a spreadsheet and i
put all that information in here
i'm going to be able to see the volume
and competition and so that's important
however one thing to note here is that
google's keyword planner
if we go back just gives us low medium
and high
and if i want to compare numbers to
numbers
maybe i want to be able to get exactly
the competition number
for the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword
so if i type in the keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
i can see there's 76 million results
so i could see 76 million results 76.1
actually and for the keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
now that's a whole lot of results for
this particular keyword
especially when the volume is only 30
uh per month on average and so what i
want to do is get a
more clear picture of the competition
and so what you could actually do is
type in the syntax
all in title and then colon and then
your keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and when i do that i get a
different result
here i can see only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist
but that's not just 136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see
when you type in a keyword or search
query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top
of every search result and so now i can
see
i typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all in
title syntax
and now i can see every listing every
one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it
so i could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me i only need to
climb over 136 listings
to rank for that keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist
and so the idea here is you want to get
your volume from google's keyword
planner
but you want to get your competition
from google search and again that's
simply typing in the
syntax call and title and then your
keyword in this example
how to become a digital marketing
specialist once you get those two
numbers
you're going to plug them in to your
spreadsheet and then once you do that
for
number of different keyword queries and
these keyword queries
again have to be relevant once you do
that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for
and that's important because again if
you're not sure
about a keyword then you want to do the
keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo
so again you want to create
content for say a keyword like digital
marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad
so you want to probably stay away from
broader keywords because broader
keywords
tend to have a lot of volume which is
great but
they may also tend to have a lot of
competition but that's the whole point
of doing the keyword research
maybe it doesn't maybe there's more
volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant
to your content that have a lot of
volume and low competition
and then once we identify those keywords
then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords
and the first place we want to start is
the title tag so
if you remember my example going back
here to our search
how to become a digital marketing
specialist we saw that every one of
these
listings had that keyword in the title
tag and the title tag is important
because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results
so they're going to see the title tag so
the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most
important factor because that's what
people see and so ideally when we choose
our keyword we want to make sure that
keyword is in the title tag
because that's what shows up in google
search and that's what makes
that particular web page relevant for
that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters
and so we want to make sure we stay
within that limit no more than
60 characters because what happens if
it's beyond that
then google will truncate the title tag
so if i go back to my search
you can see here on this particular
title tag
google truncated it meaning they added
the ellipses after the title tag because
it exceeded
the 60 character limit so you want to
stay within those character counts
and so the title tag is the first place
you should start
when optimizing your website because
when we have the right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword
then chances are it's going to be
relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks
so that's how the title tag appears so
when you optimize it
you're going to update the title tag and
this is how it shows up it's going to
show up at the top
of your listing okay and it's going to
be bigger and bolder
than anything else google displays so
the second thing you want to optimize is
the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description
up to 155 i would say about 155 to 60
160 characters but probably no more than
that
and so the meta description is nothing
more than a summary
of the web page itself so if i go back
to
my google search results i see my title
tag
and i see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see
my meta description so in this
particular keyword query how to become a
digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist
note that it's a well-written meta
description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist
so we're trying to rank for how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and here you can see become a digital
marketing specialist so there's a lot of
relevancy between
not only the title tag and the keyword
but the meta description
and the keyword so when you're
optimizing a keyword
you want to start with the title tag but
you also want to update the meta
description
because if you don't update the meta
description and you leave the meta
description blank
then you're leaving it to google to add
in
copy that they deem relevant and so for
on-page seo we want to take control of
the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for
so the meta description is a powerful
tool at our disposal
it gives us more characters to work with
it gives us more to talk about
so for that particular page and so if
the title tag is only
60 characters maximum it's not a lot of
information to try and get somebody to
click so the meta description
helps us in identifying what that page
is about
in order to get the click so the two
working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element
that's important is the url and url
stands for uniform resource
locator and why is the url so important
because
that's what people see so if i go back
to my search result
how to become a digital marketing
specialist notice that the url also
includes
how to become a digital marketing
specialist article okay so it's very
relevant the url is very relevant one we
can see it in the search results
but two you know it's relevant to the
keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and google
google wants to know hey is this the
page that's relevant to
the user's query and if it is then this
user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing
so the url is an element that helps
not only with the click-through rate but
with ranking and having a poor url
structure
doesn't help at all because not only
does google
not recognize the url as being relevant
but the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the
the way the url looks so you want to try
and avoid
a poor url structure so the rule of
thumb is this
if you don't understand what the url is
then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean
and when i say clean ideally you want to
make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize
that's the keyword that's included in
the url nothing
included that is not understandable so
again going back to our example how to
become a digital marketing
specialist it's very clean the title tag
is the keyword
the meta description is cleanly written
has the keyword
and then the url is the other element
that the end user can see
and that url includes the
keyword in it so after we've done those
three elements the title tag
the meta description and the url then we
want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself
the page remember needs to be structured
and when we say structured it needs to
be structured in terms of
you know headers and subheaders and
organized in a
manner in which the end user can read
the article
read the content clearly and concisely
without being confused
and so that's the job of headers they
add they add basically
an organizational structure to the
content and with headers there's a
hierarchy
so you have anywhere from h1 which is
the top of the hierarchy to an h6
and so you're free to use any one of
those headers when building on a page in
order to organize the content
but ideally you probably want to stick
with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google
that hey this header with this
particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an
h6 with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey
this is an h6 but it's not as important
so an h1
and an h2 tag show importance and so
let's look at an example of what that is
so here you can see an h1 is going to be
at the top of the hierarchy so that
means it's going to be bigger and bolder
then you have an h2 which is going to be
bigger and bolder than an h3
but not as big and bold as an h2 so with
headers
not only are you organizing the content
accordingly
but you're also signaling to google how
important
that particular header is and of course
the header
needs to include the keyword we're
trying to rank for
so let's take a look again at that
example so
if we go to how to become a digital
marketing specialist if i click
on that page i can look at the content
and i can see
that there are headers in here so the
headers are
there to organize the content and that's
what we want we want to be able to
organize the content and if you look at
the other example i'm showing here
how to become a digital marketing
specialist a learning path explored you
can see that's an
h1 but below it's a subheader the
growing digital marketing job market
so that's an h2 and so we're not
stressing to google that that's
more important than h1 but nonetheless
we're stressing at google that it's
important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use
keywords in our headers in order to
stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized
okay the next element we want to focus
on is
internal linking and so internal linking
if you remember
earlier in the presentation is basically
links from one page on your website to
another
and so here we can see on this
particular article
how to become a digital marketing
specialist there's also
links to other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular
content it also links to seo specialist
ppc specialist social media marketing
specialist and digital marketing
specialist
so the whole idea behind internal
linking is to link from one page to
another
where it's relevant and in this case
it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about
and so what simply learns doing here is
offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist
and so this is a best practice when
you're optimizing
a web page so you want to be able to
have internal linking on your site and
the whole idea behind internal linking
is it also allows users to navigate
through the site naturally
so when i say naturally they don't
always have to refer back to the top
navigation they can naturally and
seamlessly go from
one relevant article or page to another
and so that's the whole idea behind link
building
and internal link building it allows
google
to identify you know pages that they
want to crawl and index because they're
linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another
and it's signaling to google hey this
particular page is linked to this page
so we're going to also
index that page and so that's the whole
important part of internal linking
it's about the end user experience and
it's about allowing google to
find the pages on your website so they
can crawl them
and index them so you can be ranked for
them and so
also in addition to internal linking we
want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing
so what google does is in terms of
natural language processing
they're looking for the content and the
keyword it needs to be relevant
so when your website is about digital
marketing you don't necessarily want to
rank
or try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing one
it's too broad two there might be some
competition but three
you're probably not going to write
something as broad like digital
marketing
so ideally what you want to do is you
want to choose other
relevant related keywords that's going
to be more
natural and so that's what we mean on
natural language processing we want to
choose keywords that are more natural to
the content you're writing so instead of
the keyword digital marketing maybe
we want to talk about the types of
digital marketing or digital marketing
examples
or what is a digital marketing strategy
or how to become a digital marketing
specialist
so those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing
and more relevant to the content because
if you try to rank for the keyword
digital marketing again it's probably
going to be a little bit broad
probably more competition and not as
relevant to your content and as a result
probably not a good user experience so
think about some other keywords
that you could optimize and rank for and
that goes back to the keyword research
that's why the keyword research is so
important because it allows us to
identify
other keywords in the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content
and then another element on page seo is
the sitemap
and so with the sitemap it's basically a
list of
all the pages on your website and the
whole idea of listing
all the pages on your website in one
document
is it helps both users and search
engines
understand the structure of your website
so they do two types of sitemaps one's
an html sitemap and that's designed for
humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content
at the footer or the bottom of your web
page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that sitemap they're going to be able
to see
all the pages on your website structured
in an organized manner
well an xml sitemap and xml is just a
different format
it's designed for crawlers so if i go to
simplylearn.com and simply type in say
sitemap.xml just as an example
i'm going to get this particular page
and this particular page
displays two xml sitemaps so these
sitemaps are there
for google to go ahead and crawl and
nothing more than a list of all the
pages
on your website and so this is a quick
and easy way for google to get a hold of
all those pages
so that they can index them and that's
the whole idea behind seo
you want to be able to have google index
all the content you want to be found for
for the keywords you want to be found
for
so it all starts with the sitemap so
let's go from
on-page seo which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website
so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description
the url the headers choosing the right
keywords to put into the content having
internal linking
and also updating the sitemap well those
are elements that you can do
on your website so we're going to switch
gears and talk about a different
strategy
off-page seo because without on-page or
off-page
you can't have a page ranking so the two
work together
so you can do as much as you want on
on-page but you still need off-page seo
and you could do all the off-page seo
you want but you still need on page
so both of these strategies have to be
in full effect
in order for you to rank so let's now
switch gears to off page seo
and so off page seo is simply the
process
of linking or promoting your website
using link building
and so if you remember i talked about
this earlier on
there's two types of links internal and
external linking
and so for on-page seo we used internal
linking
for off-page seo we're going to talk
about external linking
and external linking allows us to
improve our website's recognition or
relevancy
or credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and authority
because we want google to know that our
web page
is trustworthy it is recognized by other
websites
and it is relevant for a particular
keyword and so if we can
do that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really
off-page seo synonymous with link
building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building
it just comes down to creating a
strategy so again
some of the benefits to off page well we
talked about
you know being credible and
trustworthiness and relevant we need to
do that in order to rank
but there's some other benefits there so
if we have a
link on another credible website then
it's likely
going to increase the traffic to our own
website it also
creates high domain authority and so
what i mean by high domain authority
is if we have basically links to other
web pages
pointing back to us then basically our
domain authority is going to improve and
when our domain authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher
authoritative we are for our website
then other web pages are going to
want to link to us and so the more
external linking we have the higher the
domain authority
so it all starts with linking to other
high
domain authority websites so linking to
a high
domain authority website for example
having a link on wikipedia that points
back to our web page
creates high domain authority for us and
it helps drive traffic
so some of the other benefits of
off-page seo
are credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia
to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking
helps build domain authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn
help us rank for that particular page
and then certainly not last
having a good off-page seo link building
strategy
increases our brand awareness because if
we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform
it's going to increase our brand
awareness and increasing our brand
awareness
increases our trustworthiness and so if
somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in
digital marketing specialist on google
they may type in our brand name in this
case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to
off-page seo
so it's nothing more than having
links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours
and again there's lots of benefits it's
drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of
when we want to rank and the key behind
off page seo or link building is always
going to be
content so from an on-page seo
perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be
optimized for relevant keyword and
ranked but also
from an off-page seo strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
linked back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind
off page you can't have links on other
websites if you don't have quality
content
so one of the ideas behind off page seo
is not only do you want to create good
content but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about
having an ice cream blog and ice cream
recipes well it probably wouldn't be a
bad idea
to say spend some time on other blogs
related to
desserts related to cakes related to
food in general
related to vegetables or other items
that
people could link from so the whole idea
is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you
and generally that's how it works
naturally anyway in the
web sphere if somebody likes your
content they're going to link to it
they don't necessarily have to wait for
you to ask them but
it might not be a bad idea to understand
who else is out there that has content
similar to yours
so that you can you know get a link on
that particular website or blog post
and so some other ideas behind having
external links pointing back to your
website
is social media so social media is not
just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core
there's medium there's all sorts of
content generated websites like reddit
so the list goes on and on you just need
to find what's relevant
for your content if it's relevant for
your content
then it's worth putting or trying to get
the external link
on that social media platform and then
again going back to my ice cream blog
recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog
that you want to have an external link
on there's nothing wrong with reaching
out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant
then why not it's only going to help
your end user experience
if you add somebody who has a say a blog
about
cakes having their link on your blog
post
so there's nothing wrong with it because
it also adds to the user experience
and if you're going to ask somebody to
put an external link on theirs
you might want to be open-minded and
make sure that you're
are able and willing to put an external
link on your blog post or website
pointing to their content that's how the
web works especially if the contents of
quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo
so we talked a lot about why seo what is
seo
you know how do we rank for seo what is
on page seo what is off page seo
and so let's just wrap up with some of
the things you again
want to do to rank your page for a
particular keyword
and some of the things you don't want to
do so the first thing on the list is
optimize for white hat techniques and
what i mean
for opting in for white hat techniques
is basically everything i just mentioned
today
you want to do keyword research you want
to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content
and you don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth
going into detail but one example is
choosing a keyword
arbitrarily like say digital marketing
and just stuffing that keyword into the
content
so that's probably not something you
want to do because again it's not going
to be good for the
end user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's
presentation the other do we want to do
is get backlinks from relevant sites
so that's off-page seo again it's
what i mentioned earlier it's about
linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has
quality content we don't want to have a
backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority
because if it's on a site that's not of
good quality
then google is going to look at us and
say well
this site is linking to your site but
it's not relevant
so therefore you know we're not going to
look at you
in the same way as if you were on a
quality website we do want to use our
keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on
organic search but you don't want to use
the same title tag
on every page of your website so we want
to stay away from
doing that so you want to have a unique
title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using
our keyword research to choose one or
two keywords for
page and optimizing your web page for
those
one to two keywords so you ideally what
you want to do is have one to two
different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely
want to write engaging content so the
content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading
and we want them to go from one page to
another naturally
we definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just
copy content from others websites
because it's not
one probably going to be relevant to
what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's
so that's a black cat technique we want
to stay away from
i can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords
and not only that you need to understand
the volume
and the competition for each of those
keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume
high competition you want to choose a
keyword
that has high volume low competition
but above all you want to choose
keywords that are relevant
to your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing
so don't take a keyword and just stuff
it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to
maintain some level of quality with our
content
and quality with the keywords that we
choose so reminder
when you have quality content it's
always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content
but it's got to be natural and don't
just build site-wide backlinks meaning
don't just have an internal link to the
home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just
one page so internal linking should be
natural
naturally linking from one page to
another not only does it help
google understand and crawl all the web
pages on your website
but it's good for the end user it's good
user experience
and certainly last but something i
didn't talk about
does take time to rank your content so
remember the process you're going to
write your content you're going to
choose keywords you're going to change
the elements on that page for those
keywords
and all the while you're going to make
sure google can crawl that content
and when they crawl they're going to
index it the process takes time
especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient
if you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page seo
and off-page seo then you will rank for
that keyword
and then make sure your website's
user-friendly
and mobile friendly so we talked about
responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today
start the process of search on mobile so
we want to make sure your websites
are mobile friendly
so i want to thank you for joining me
today i look forward to seeing you
on other simply learn presentations
so thank you for your time and for more
information
please feel free to visit
simplylearn.com thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here